tout aussi la f1 et le port de montréal
dont on va discuter avec michel leblanc
le pdg pdg de la chambre de commerce du
montréal métropolitain bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fillon alors été préférable
d'avoir deux ans plus 2030 31 dans
l'entente avec le grand prix que d'avoir
eu un grand prix à huis clos cette année
ben vous poser la question et la réponse
est évidente
l'intérêt de tenir d'un grand prix du
point de vue de l'investissement c'est
d'avoir des gens c'est d'avoir des gens
qui viennent de l'étranger c'est d'avoir
ces dizaines de milliers de dollars de
retombées économiques dans toute
l'économie
alors on les change cette année un
événement qui aurait été sans impact
c'est évidemment les gens qui aiment la
formule heures et regarde à la télé mais
sans impact cette année contre deux
années additionnelles avec des impacts
maximum et moi j'en retiens que on vient
d'avoir un message d'intérêts
convergents c'est à dire que on le
voulait à montréal mais la formule 1le
accepter aussi donc c'est un nouveau
climat on se rappelle dans le passé
c'était comme un peu humiliant de
négocier avec la formule 1 là ça s'est
bien fait moi je lève mon chapeau à tous
ceux qui ont négocié du point de vue du
québec du canada pour qu'ils ont fait un
bon travail mais 19 millions cette année
en 2021 que ça aurait dû coûter l'on est
à 25 il ya 26 millions pour 2030 et 2031
cc l'inflation pourquoi ça coûte plus
cher mais je vais vous parler un petit
peu ces 18 19 millions cette année
mais rendue dans les dernières années de
l'entente était plutôt 19 20 donc c'est
simplement pour dire qu'il y avait déjà
un peu d'inflation qui était dans
l'entente 19 20 michel puis on s'envoie
25 25
alors évidemment ce que ça présuppose
c'est que la valeur de la formule 1 va
augmenter dans le temps la valeur des
retombées on l'espère vont suivre moi
j'en retiens beaucoup aussi
les 5 autres millions dont vous avez
parlé qui sont pour la campagne
promotionnelle
je pense que le plus grand défi qu'on a
tous ses comptes doit se regarder c'est
comment on aura même les touristes dès
la prochaine année
et la formule 1 dès la prochaine année
festival montréal accueillant le québec
accueillant il ya un et une énorme
offensive à faire et ça prend 10 ou donc
le 5 millions additionnels moi je le
vois comme étant un très bon
investissement
les quelques millions additionnels pour
dans dix ans je les vois comme étant un
investissement également les retombées
sont évoqués que ça sera payant mais est
ce que vous trouvez pas qu'on agit par
excès de prudence quand même en annulant
grand prix de montréal dans votre for
intérieur nous sommes le seul grand prix
annulé cette année
écoutez encore une fois tout cela doit
être pris en ligne de compte avec la
santé publique je dois vous avouer que
je nous trouve au québec
à ce moment ci très catastrophique on a
l'impression qu'on est tellement
traumatisée par la troisième vague et
les variants qu'on n'est pas capable
d'observer quand israël et qu en
angleterre par exemple où ils sont en
avance sur la vaccination les choses
ouvre un contrôle mais elle ouvre donc
est-ce que juin je pense que je vois
c'est la zone qui était très difficile à
lire
si grand prix avait eu lieu en juillet
ou en août le jeune homme on le réussit
nous aurait trouvé beaucoup trop prudent
en juin je comprends totalement la
sécurité de la santé publique d'être
prudente je pense que c'est la zone
encore très difficile celle de juin mais
juin juillet où je comprends qu'il aura
pas d'événements majeurs cet été à
montréal et est bien là vous arrive à
une conclusion plus vite que moi moi
j'ai l'impression que ce qui s'en vient
a été nuls et le mépris est annulé et le
jazz et les francofolies sont reportés
au mode se tendre
je vous entends moi je serais pas
surpris que si la vaccination vont bon
train
qu'on commence à anticiper camp nou on
pourra faire des choses et il y aura
peut-être des sous pour organiser des
événements dès le mois d'août moi j'ai
vraiment l'impression que la population
la seconde qu'elle va sentir qu'elle
peut se rassembler parce que la
vaccination aura atteint un certain
seuil
voilà demandé je pense que les
politiques veulent autoriser à ce moment
là le grand défi c'est que ça s'organise
pas sur indices ou des festivals des
actifs et soeurs ça ça doit se planifier
alors lorsque je pense qu'il doit se
passer c'est que des gens planifient des
peut-être des possibles pour le mois
d'août pour voir si jamais ça vaut la
peine de le faire
port de montréal est ce que la loi
spéciale samedi probablement vigueur la
vous satisfait
oui évidemment quelqu'un pourrait dire
on l'avait vu venir on aurait pu
décréter une loi spéciale préemptif mais
ça n'arrive pas en politique c'est la
crise qui force le geste maintenant ça
se passe très rapidement je lève encore
une fois mon chapeau on avait interpellé
directement le 1er mai justin trudeau
il a donné les ordres à long terme pour
que c'est toi la spéciale soit déposé
j'ai un hommage au parti conservateur
qui a décrété qu en fait qui a décidé de
l'appuyer
je questionne beaucoup le bloc québécois
parce que le premier ministre du québec
les ministres à québec
tout le monde le dit c'est essentiel
pour notre économie mais au moins ça va
arriver
une fois que ce sera en place se
poseraient la question comment éviter
que ça se reproduise dans cinq ans
comment éviter le psychodrame à
intervalles réguliers ou de toute
évidence ces deux parties la négocie
difficilement
ça n'a pas de sens que toute l'économie
soit dépendent heures de négociations
quelques employeurs maritimes et mills
un débardeur ça n'a pas de sens
michel leblanc merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit